- Good afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
My name is Jeff Brenzel
and I teach here at Yale
in the Philosophy and
Humanities departments.
In my role as Master of
Timothy Dwight College
I am also the official steward
of the Chubb Fellowship
at Yale University.
So it is on behalf of
the Chubb Fellowship,
of Timothy Dwight College,
of the President and officers
and fellows of Yale
University, the faculty
and staff and students of Yale,
and the entire New Haven area community
that we welcome His
Holiness the 17th Karmapa
and His delegation to our
community and to our campus.
I want to recognize
briefly the co-sponsors
and the other collaborators
who have worked hard to arrange
and support the visit of His Holiness
and His delegation here to Yale.
In addition to the Chubb Fellowship,
these are the Yale Himalaya Initiative,
the Forum on Religion and Ecology,
the Yale Religious Studies Department,
the Yale School of Forestry
and Environmental Studies,
the Yale Divinity School
and the MacMillan Center
for International and Area Studies.
We are particularly grateful, of course,
to His Holiness himself
for His generosity of time
and spirit in making himself
astonishingly available
during His time here, putting
forth a strenuous effort
to meet or speak or connect
with so many communities within
and without the university who hoped
for the opportunity to see and hear Him
during His stay here at Yale.
I want to make special
mention of the many members
of the Tibetan community from
the entire eastern region
of the United States,
who have traveled here
to be with us this afternoon, as well
as many other Buddhist
brothers and sisters
from other lands and places.
To all of you I want to
extend our warmest welcome.
(audience applauding)
Here this afternoon His Holiness
will be presenting this year's
Chubb Fellowship address.
And I should say just a brief word
about the fellowship itself.
Hendon Chubb was an 1895 graduate
of Yale's Sheffield Scientific School,
and in 1936 he made a substantial
gift to the university
with the intent of
encouraging Yale's students
to take a particular
interest in public service.
Since 1949, as Hendon
Chubb himself approved,
the university has used his endowment
to underwrite a visiting speakers program
bringing extraordinary
public figures to the campus.
Past Chubb fellows include four presidents
of the United States, presidents
of eight other countries,
Nobel and other
international prize winners,
and more than 150 other regional, national
and internationally prominent persons,
all of whom have been noteworthy
in some particular way
for their personal distinction in service
to the common good of all.
It is now my honor to ask
Andrew Quintman to the podium.
Professor Quintman teaches at Yale
in the Department of Religious Studies,
where he specializes in the
Buddhist traditions of Tibet
and the Himalaya.
His work surveys Buddhist
literature and history,
sacred geography and pilgrimage,
and the visual cultures of
the wider Himalayan region.
He has written several books
on the early Tibetan saint
Milarepa, including an English translation
of The Life of Milarepa,
who is a founding figure
in the Karmapa's Lineage.
Please welcome professor Quintman.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, Jeff.
Good afternoon.
It is my great pleasure and distinct honor
to introduce His Holiness the 17th Karmapa
Ogyen Trinley Dorje, who
will share with us today
His insight and vision
on three crucial topics
for our time: compassion,
religion, and the environment.
In 1949, at the request of
Yale's Beinecke Rare Book
and Manuscript Library, 100 volumes
of the Tibetan Buddhist Canon were printed
from wood blocks in Lhasa,
wrapped in leather satchels
and loaded onto ponies.
They traveled by caravan to Calcutta
and then freighter to New Haven,
where they arrived in 1950
and were installed in the
library with great ceremony.
This gift presented to Yale
by the current Dalai Lama,
who was only 14 years old
at the time and still living
in Lhasa, planted a seed of
Yale's connection to Tibet,
a seed that has now
taken root and blossomed
with the visit by His
Holiness the Karmapa.
The Karmapa is part of a Tibetan tradition
of formally recognized
reincarnations known as Tulku,
wherein a young child is
identified as the re-embodiment
of a deceased master.
The Karmapas are the head
of the Karma Kagyu branch
of Tibetan Buddhism, and are the oldest
such reincarnation lineage
in the Himalayan region,
extending back some 900 years.
His Holiness Ogyen Trinley
Dorje is the 17th in his line.
The first Karmapa, Dusum Khyenpa, was born
in the early 12th century, and
is said to have left a letter
for telling the conditions
of his future rebirth.
Since then such prediction
letters have become a hallmark
of the lineage, and together
with other religious signs,
have been used to identify
subsequent Karmapas.
The second Karmapa, Karma
Pakshi, was renowned
for his spiritual mastery,
which led to his invitation
to the court of Kublai Khan.
The third Karmapa,
Rangjung Dorje, was famous
for his exegesis on philosophy
and esoteric Buddhist theory.
And subsequent Karmapas became consummate
religious teachers, great
scholars, virtuoso meditators,
artists and poets.
They were also teachers who
carried out the activities
of a Buddha, as the title Karmapa
is sometimes etymologized.
The 16th Karmapa, Rangjung
Rigpe Dorje, fled Tibet in 1959
and established a monastic
seat in Sikkim, India.
He is remembered for his
great love of animals,
especially birds, and also for his ability
to communicate with them.
The 16th was part of an early
wave of Tibetan teachers
who brought traditional
Buddhist teachings to the West.
He visited the United States first in 1974
and again in 1977.
And during this period he established
a major monastic center
outside Woodstock, New York,
which now has dozens of affiliated centers
around the world.
Ogyen Trinley Dorje was born
in 1985 in Eastern Tibet,
and based upon his
predecessors prediction letter
and testament he was
recognized and then enthroned
as the 17th Karmapa at
the traditional monastery
of his lineage at
Tsurphu in Central Tibet.
And I was fortunate to meet
His Holiness numerous times
at Tsurphu, and it was clear even then
that he was an extraordinary individual.
In 1999 he determined
that he was no longer able
to receive an adequate
religious education inside Tibet
and so, over the course of
eight days, in late December
and early January, he
undertook a harrowing journey
across the Himalayan range.
The story is quite dramatic.
It includes a daring escape
through an upper storey window
of the monastery, a trek
across frozen mountain passes
and horseback travel
through Northern Nepal.
He eventually reached Dharamsala in India,
where he maintains a close relationship
with another of Tibet's
great religious figures,
the 14th Dalai Lama.
At 29 years old, His Holiness
is already recognized
as a leading religious
figure of his generation,
as an accomplished Buddhist teacher.
But he is also a prolific
artist, poet and playwright.
He is a religious reformer
dedicated to gender equality
and the restoration of Bhikṣuṇī
or full monastic ordination for women.
He's a social activist
committed to human rights,
vegetarianism and the
ethical treatment of animals.
He is an environmentalist
focused on the protection
of Himalayan landscapes
and natural resources
through an eco-monastic
program called Khoryug,
the Tibetan word for environment,
that networks more than
50 religious institutions
across the Himalaya.
In His Holiness's own
words, "Whatever it is I do,
"I wanted to have a
long-term visible impact
"and for it to be practical.
"If I have the opportunity,
I would most like
"to restore the natural
environment in the Himalayas
"and Tibet and to especially
protect the forests,
"the water and the
wildlife of the region."
And I think it is not
an exaggeration to say
that His Holiness the 17th Karmapa
will revolutionize Buddhism, not only
in the Tibetan tradition
but also on a global scale.
The reach of the Karmapa's
activities is reflected
in the way that his visit
has brought people across...
Has brought people together
across Yale University,
from the Arts and
Sciences to Public Health
and Environmental Studies, faculty,
graduate students and undergraduates.
Some time ago, long before
His Holiness's visit
had been publicly announced,
one of the eight Tibetans
who works at Yale appeared in my office
and enthusiastically said, "I
read the Karmapa is coming!"
Well, he was.
Today's address, entitled
Compassion in Action:
Buddhism and the Environment,
is the direct result
of converging interests, or
as Buddhists like to say,
of causes and conditions,
that span the University
and its wider community.
So the seed first
planted some 65 years ago
has now begun to flower.
So please join me now in
welcoming His Holiness
the 17th Karmapa.
(audience applauding)
You want to stand next
to me or you wanna sit?
It's just for a minute.
(audience applauding)
So thank you Your Holiness.
So let me conclude with just a few words
about today's program.
Following His Holiness's address,
he will be joined on stage by myself
and my colleague Mary Evelyn
Tucker for a short conversation
about the main themes
of the talk: compassion,
religion and the environment.
Mary Evelyn is a senior
lecturer and research scholar
at Yale University, where she teaches
in a joint Master's degree
program between the School
of Forestry and Environmental Studies
and the Yale Divinity School.
And she is also, and
perhaps more importantly,
the director of the Forum
on Religion and Ecology
at Yale together with
her husband John Grim.
The program will conclude
with an opportunity
for His Holiness to address
questions from the audience.
Now, over the past week or
so, we've collected questions
by email from those who
would attend today's address
and we have received an
enthusiastic response
and have selected a
representative sample of them.
So I would be remiss if
I did not acknowledge
at least a few individuals
who were instrumental
in making His Holiness's
visit to Yale possible.
So my heartfelt thanks go, of course,
to the Chubb Fellowship,
to Master Jeff Brenzel
and Susan Wiggler, to George
Joseph of the Macmillan Center
for International and Area
Studies, and, of course,
to the incredible staff,
the indefatigable staff
of the Yale Himalaya Initiative,
including program director Alark Saxena,
Anobha Gurung, Priyankar
Chand and Sangye Dorje.
So Your Holiness.
- Thank you.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Interpreter] First
I'd like to welcome each
and every one of you.
Tashi Delek.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Tashi Delek means may you be filled
with auspicious goodness and joy.
(speaking in foreign language)
- And I would also like to thank
everyone at Yale University
who has been responsible for inviting me
and giving me this opportunity to be here.
(speaking in foreign language)
- And I would also like
to thank all of you
who have come here today.
(speaking in foreign language)
(coughing)
- This is my third visit to
the United States of America,
and whenever I come here I have
a special feeling of freedom
and joy, especially this
time, the third time,
as I've been visiting
several universities.
I've been overjoyed by
the experience of meeting
with many students and
witnessing a little bit
of their study and university life.
(coughs)
(speaking in foreign language)
- Now, the topic you've asked
me to address is compassion
and the environment.
(speaking in foreign language)
- To give you a little bit of background,
many people have asked
me, "What inspired you
"to become so concerned
about the environment?"
So I'm gonna talk a little
bit about that to begin.
(speaking in foreign language)
- I was born in a quite
isolated part of Eastern Tibet,
and where I was born there had been
no great modern development,
so I lived in a very natural
and somewhat pristine environment.
Until I was seven, this
was the only environment
in which I lived.
So I experienced firsthand
as a child a feeling
of intimate connection with
the natural environment,
and I retained to this day a constant
and extremely clear recollection of this.
(speaking in foreign language)
- For example, where
I was born we regarded
and experienced our environment
as a living system, living beings.
The mountains, the sources
of water were all regarded
as the dwelling places of
what I would call holy spirits
of various kinds.
We therefore respected every
aspect of the environment
as part of a living system.
We didn't wash our
clothes or even our hands
in a flowing water sources.
We didn't cast any kind of garbage
or any kind of other pollutant
into the fire in our hearth.
So we regarded the entire
environment as innately sacred.
(speaking in foreign language)
- One of the challenges
that those who live
in such an environment
face nowadays is the use
of artificial and non
biodegradable substances,
because for the first
time they have to deal
with real garbage.
We didn't really have garbage
because we used pretty well everything up,
and anything that we did dispose of
was easily biodegradable.
And now, because of the
introduction of artificial materials
that are not biodegradable,
we have to come up
with new ways to dispose of them.
And so this, to give you one example,
is changing the lifestyle
of people in such places.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Obviously, as a child, I
had no knowledge of philosophy
or science, but I had a strong
emotional connection with
and strong feelings for the environment,
which means that now that I've
begun to acquire a little bit
of knowledge, it isn't
just knowledge for me,
it's based on my strong feelings.
(speaking in foreign language)
- I think that in order to
understand the necessity
of environmental protection,
we need to understand
how connected we are to one
another and to our environment.
So, in order to understand
our connectedness,
I think we need to
understand interdependence.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Lots of echo.
- Yeah, I'm having a really
hard time hearing, I'm sorry.
- What do we do?
- I don't know.
Maybe if I move back.
- Really?
- Might be better.
(mumbling)
(audience laughing)
- Maybe you can sit down?
- No.
(mumbling)
(laughing)
(speaking in foreign language)
- For example, for us to
acquire or eat any food,
have clothes to wear or even
to have the bodies we do,
all of these things require
the interconnectedness
of many aspects of many
things and many people
within the environment.
(speaking in foreign language)
- The value of understanding
interdependence in this regard
is that we often feel at some
distance from our environment.
We divide the world into
subject and object and we feel
that the external environment is an object
separated from us by some kind of boundary
and at some distance from we,
from ourselves as subjects.
We need to dissolve
this artificial boundary
and decrease the distance
between ourselves
and our environment.
(speaking in foreign language)
- And I think if we do that we can begin
to feel how connected we
are to our environment
and how little distance, if any,
there really is between
ourselves and our environment.
(speaking in foreign language)
- In Tibetan we often
refer to the relationship
between the external
environment and the beings
who inhabit that environment
as the relationship
between a container and its contents.
We are all held by and within
the environment we inhabit.
We are like the contents
or even the nutrients
within such an environment,
and it seems that it's
necessary for us to begin
to acknowledge that interrelationship.
(speaking in foreign language)
- We therefore also need
to acknowledge the fact
that our environment can affect us
and we can also affect our environment.
Some people have the idea that
the environment is so vast
and so primordial that nothing
we do is actually going
to affect it.
Unfortunately, that's been
proven not to be the case,
and we need to begin to
acknowledge the interdependence,
that the aspect of interdependence,
that is our effect on the environment,
even as our environment affects us.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Well, we need to
acknowledge these things.
Mere knowledge or
understanding alone, of course,
is not enough.
One of our problems is that
we tend to separate ourselves
as persons from our
knowledge or understanding.
And if we understand
or know about the need
for environmental protection,
but do not apply it
in our daily lives, we're not
going to achieve anything.
Our knowledge or understanding
has to become so intimate,
so personal to us, that it
naturally changes our behavior,
that we feel it emotionally
and in our hearts.
(speaking in foreign language)
- We need therefore to
reflect upon the fact
that our knowledge of the
environment really is a knowledge
of something that's going
to affect our lives,
a knowledge of something that is going
to affect our well-being.
(speaking in foreign language)
- And I think it is in
that regard that spiritual
and religious traditions
can serve the cause
of environmental stewardship.
(speaking in foreign language)
- And when I say religious traditions,
I don't just mean Buddhist traditions,
I mean every religious
tradition in this world
can play its part, and I'm
confident that if we do this,
if we work together, if
we apply the knowledge
that is embodied in the
many indigenous cultures
that have survived, the ancient
wisdom of our ancestors,
we will be able to discover together
that environmental protection
is not just a point of view,
not just science, but
must be a way of life.
(speaking in foreign language)
- At various times in our history, science
and religion have seemed to be
contradictory to one another,
have even become enemies,
attacked one another, or,
to be more polite, refuted one another.
But really there is a great
commonality of experience
that we all share.
We're all human beings
living in the same world,
relying on the same environment.
And therefore, on that basis, on the basis
of acknowledging our shared
or common experience,
we have to accept that the
protection of this environment
is beyond the views of any one religion.
(speaking in foreign language)
- If we base our approach
to environmental stewardship
on being loving and compassionate,
there should be no contradiction
between science and spirituality.
We can share, undertake and
share our common responsibility
for this environment, and
in that way actually put
into practice and make
practical use of the information
that scientists give us
about the environment,
and not live as though
we are in denial of it.
(speaking in foreign language)
- The Himalaya, including the Tibetan...
And the Tibetan plateau are
considered a treasury of water
that feed the great rivers of Asia
and therefore supply so much water
that the, sometimes, the
Himalaya is called a third Pole.
Therefore we have to
be especially concerned
with the environment in the Himalaya
and conservation of water there.
So what we have tried to do is
train monasteries in best...
Himalayan monasteries in
best environmental practices
so that they can then
present these to their local
or neighboring communities.
(speaking in foreign language)
- When this subject was first
introduced to representatives
of these monasteries,
they were immediately
emotionally affected and
demonstrated tremendous commitment
to environmental
stewardship in their region,
but at the same time we
lack a scientific knowledge
and technical expertise.
So in order to do this we need the support
of the scientific community
and the assistance
of the scientific community.
And I mentioned this as an example of how,
in order to preserve our environment,
we all need to work together
and offer our individual
skills and knowledge.
(speaking in foreign language)
- I'm going to end my initial
address or talk with that
and we'll begin the conversation.
Before we do, however, I
again want to thank each
and every one of you for coming here,
and convey to you my sincere delight
in having this opportunity.
- Thank you.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
(coughs)
- Thank you.
- [Andrew] (mumbling) glass of water.
- Thank you Your Holiness,
and thank you translator.
- Yeah.
- We wanted to begin by
picking up on a point
that you've made earlier--
- Yes.
- About the route of compassion
is having a steadfast heart,
the power of the heart.
And this work with the environment
for many people can be discouraging
because it's so overwhelming right now.
So could you speak about this
need for a steadfast heart,
the power of the heart in compassion?
- Mm-hm.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Well, first of all, I would
say that many activists,
and especially environmental activists,
naturally become highly
emotionally invested
in their activism.
And when after years and
years of very hard work
they don't see a great deal of result,
they can become a little
bit embittered and angry.
(clears throat)
(speaking in foreign language)
(interpreter laughs)
- And if you spend enough time listening
to one dire prediction about the future
of this planet after another
from environmental scientists,
even we listeners can develop a little bit
of a problem in our brains.
(Mary laughs)
- Yeah.
(speaking in foreign language)
- I think there are two
levels or types of activism,
and the one is what we all practice.
We can practice it by being supportive
of intensive activism, but
even if we are in denial
of the need for environmental activism,
because we're having an
effect on the environment,
you can call it a type of mirror activism.
(speaking in foreign language)
- The other type of activist
is what we would normally refer
to as a non environmental activist.
And that's someone who
intentionally undertakes
responsibility and puts great
effort into the achievement
of, in this case, environmental
goals and changes.
I think that one thing
that's very important is
for those of us who are
less directly involved
to take some responsibility
and be supportive
as much as we can of
environmental activism,
because if you look at the situation,
there is absolutely no reason not
to support environmental activism.
(speaking in foreign language)
- To use myself as an
example, I'm a vegetarian.
And becoming vegetarian,
which in my case is partly
for environmental reasons, is something
that anyone can do.
It doesn't require an organization,
it doesn't require extensive
scientific knowledge
or anything like that.
But, nevertheless, as simple as it is,
when you do that, when you
make that kind of change
in your life, it's very
encouraging, because you realize
that you're not without power,
you have the ability, even as one person,
to do at least something
that is beneficial
to the environment.
(speaking in foreign language)
- I think that the greatest
source of courage for us
in environmental stewardship comes
from making such simple
changes in our lives
and realizing how much power we do have.
- Yes.
- [Andrew] Thank you.
- [Mary] Thank you.
- So Your Holiness, just to
follow up on that last point,
you raised the question
in The Heart is Noble,
where you said, "What
does it take for our ideas
"to move our heart so that
is what is it that moves us
"to overcome our habits and
desires like meat-eating
"or mass consumerism?"
So I wonder if you could say a little bit
about what it means to
move past good intentions
and move into actual action.
- Lots of echo, actually.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Oh, so consumerism
are you talking about?
- Yes.
- Sure.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
(speaking in foreign language)
- You mean how to bridge--
- Yeah.
- Good intentions into...
(speaking in foreign language)
- Actually, you can repeat that, I guess?
- [Andrew] Sure.
- I'm sorry.
- Your Holiness, you mentioned yourself
you've written before and
in talks that you've given
that when you were quite
young you were fond
of eating meat but you
had the good intention
of giving that up.
You're now--
- Yeah.
- A vegetarian
- Yes.
- And that is taking a good
intention and putting it into--
- Still I like meat.
But it's okay.
- But many people wonder
how to take a good intention
and to actually put it into practice.
- Okay.
(audience laughing)
Put it into practice.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Well, to use the example you
brought up, my vegetarianism,
as you mentioned, as a child I ate meat.
In fact, I only stopped eating
meat about eight years ago.
So I kept on eating meat for many years,
but I knew it was wrong.
I still ate it.
(speaking in foreign language)
- In that type of case, I think that...
The bridge is a type of
compassion, a type of courage,
the power of your heart.
And by the power of your heart I mean that
which enables us to
decide once and for all
to take responsibility for our own actions
as individuals, to be able to
commit ourselves to accepting
and fulfilling our
responsibilities as a person.
(speaking in foreign language)
- So the bridge is that
a mere understanding
become more emotionally felt,
and a deep emotional feeling
based on understanding
will inspire us to take action
once we listen to the
advice of our hearts.
- Thank you.
- You spoke on science and religion,
a very important topic,
a very complex topic.
I'd love you to speak a little bit more
because for many years--
- Mm-hm.
- Scientists have been speaking--
- Yeah.
- About climate change
and the environment.
And now there's a new moment
when some scientists are saying
this is no longer an
issue of science alone
but a moral issue.
- Mm-hm.
- And that's what your work encourages us
in this new dialogue of
science and religion.
Can you speak on that?
(speaking in foreign language)
(interpreter sighs)
- As you said, environmental
protection or conservation
is fundamentally a moral issue.
And the reason, the founding,
the crucial factor in it
that makes it a moral issue
is that the degradation
or destruction of the
environment has been caused
by human greed.
And our human greed, bad
enough as it is to start with,
has only been exacerbated
and fed by our media
and our advertising industry.
The problem we face therefore
is that human desire
is limitless, but environmental
resources are limited.
And therefore it is our
responsibility as those
who depend on these resources to rein in
and control our greed.
In order that we start
doing so it is essential
that religious leaders, spiritual leaders,
spiritual teachers, not only preach
about individual practice issues
or individual moral codes
but also about global issues
and that they provide moral guidance
on environmental stewardship,
because they are the ones
who can evoke feeling,
evoke enthusiasm, evoke
an emotional commitment
in their followers.
Until we accept the fact
that our environment
is not external to us, it pervades us,
it's within our bodies
and our minds as well,
it will be difficult for
us to change our behavior.
But the key to becoming really motivated,
to change the way we
live, and thereby begin
to heal the environment, the
key that will open the door
to that type of motivation,
seems to be in the hands
of those religious and spiritual
leaders who are willing
to provide moral guidance
concerning the environment
that is based on sound
scientific knowledge.
- [Andrew] Thank you.
- Thank you.
So to take the conversation
in a slightly different direction,
Your Holiness, you
spoke about the practice
of dissolving the distinction
between subject and object,
the inner and outer worlds.
And, of course, there are many techniques
for putting that into
practice in meditation.
We can study about that,
you can practice it,
but I wonder, does the
practice of cultivating,
of dissolving that
distinction naturally lead
to a feeling of connection
for the environment,
for an appreciation of the environment?
- No.
Appreciation.
(speaking in foreign language)
- We have a number of
meditation practices,
as you mentioned in
your question, concerned
with dissolvering, dissolving, excuse me,
the false boundary between self and other.
One of these is contemplating
the equality of oneself
and others, which is
fundamentally developing
an empathetic recognition that
just as I want to be happy
and not suffer so do others,
and that in that we're exactly the same.
And once you have taken this to heart,
then of course you have
to put it into practice
and live accordingly.
We also do meditations on
exchanging one's self for others,
where you actually imagine
yourself in the position
of another and that other
in the position of yourself,
and you try to imagine as
wholeheartedly as 100% as possible
how they feel, what they're going through,
and then apply that.
So there should be ways to
extrapolate from these techniques
and apply them to environmental awareness.
(speaking in foreign language)
- For example, if we think
about the fact that trees,
so to speak, breathe out,
what we need to breathe in,
oxygen, and we breathe out carbon dioxide,
which they seem to need to,
so to speak, breathe in,
so that our exhaust is their air
and their exhaust is our air, it's...
This is something we don't need
to imagine, this is a fact.
So, if you contemplate that,
just the interrelationship
or interconnectedness of
breathing, of our breathing
and the vegetation, things that grow,
that could be a meditation
technique in and of itself,
because if you feel that, you realize
that we're really two
parts of one whole machine
or one whole system.
- We wanted to give a
chance for a few questions
from the audience which
were submitted in advance.
So maybe two.
- Yeah, two.
- I look at some very good questions.
- Thank you.
- The first one is on climate change.
- Mm-hm.
- Climate change or global warming appears
to be the world's greatest crisis,
but there are many people who
deny global warming exists.
What advice would you give
to working with people
in the government who
believe there is no need
to protect the environment?
(sighing)
(laughing)
- I don't have all the solutions.
(audience applauding)
I think this is...
Oh.
- You don't have to answer it.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- Maybe.
Oh, yeah, this...
(speaking in foreign language)
(interpreter laughs)
(interpreter sighs)
- Well, the climate
change is a huge process.
It's very vast, it has all
kinds of sub bits and pieces,
and it's somewhat a gradual process,
so that we don't directly feel
it or notice it day by day.
By the time that we all
feel climate change,
it will be far too late
to do anything about it.
So there really are two
levels of denial here.
There's the denial of those
who are actual climate change deniers:
politicians and others.
And then there's the denial
that most of us live in
of climate change, where because
we don't actually feel it
it's not really in our
minds most of the time.
And then there are little
pockets of odd reactions.
For example, Tibetans...
Tibet is a very cold country.
It's often hard to get warm enough,
and so the global warming,
some Tibetans have greeted this
with enthusiasm, (Mary laughs)
thinking it doesn't get
as cold as it used to,
it's much more pleasant.
As for what to do about
politicians and others
who are active or outspoken
climate change deniers,
the best thing might
be to appeal to support
from religious and spiritual leaders
because they have so much influence
over their respective
communities or devotees.
- [Andrew] Yes.
- Thank you.
- So Your Holiness, the last
question is one a number
of our undergraduate students asked,
and that is how can students
in a university like Yale
organize themselves to take
fruitful and positive action
for the environment?
What can they do that's practical?
(sighing)
(speaking in foreign language)
- Of course there are several
things we can do as groups
or communities, the usual types
of environmental activism,
demonstrations, raising
our voice and so on,
but fundamentally each of us
has to start with ourselves,
because the only solid basis
for the type of courage
it's going to take to
actually make these changes
comes when you have made
changes in your own life
and have begun to feel
the effects of that,
and that courage can't
be taken away from you,
so you won't lose it in the process
of a long career of activism.
Otherwise, if we attempt to
change or convince others
to change without having changed the way
we live our lives ourselves,
we will be fueling ourselves
not with an internal courage
but with expectations.
And when others don't change
the way we would like them to,
we'll become disillusioned
and possibly totally
burned out altogether.
So we have to start whatever
we may do, on a social
or communal level, we have to start
by making individual
changes in our own lives.
And then another thing
that is necessary is
to have a support community, a
supportive community of those
who share one's own environmental
aspirations and ideals.
- Thank you.
- [Andrew] Thank you.
- We'd like to conclude
by thanking His Holiness
for reigniting hope this evening.
And I'd like to say it was 20 years ago
that we began a project
at Harvard actually
with one of the first conferences
on Buddhism and ecology.
- Yes.
- And then the other
world religions and ecology.
But it is our great joy that
Yale has picked up this idea
that religions and
ecology can work together,
which you have highlighted today.
And our school of Forestry
and Environmental Studies,
with the students there and
students from Religious Studies
and Divinity, I think are giving us hope
because they understand this,
they want to work with your communities,
and we want to figure
ways into the future.
I want to end though with a special thanks
to our Dean, Peter Crane,
who has held up this effort
between the School
of Forestry Environmental
Studies and Divinity.
And tomorrow night we're going
to continue the conversation
with Peter Crane, scientists,
ethicists and so on
between these two schools to examine
the new papal encyclical
which will be coming out
this summer exactly on this issue,
which can affect a billion Catholics,
two billion Christians, but be
in dialogue with the efforts
that you're doing.
So tomorrow night at Lindsay
Hall on High Street at 5:30,
we invite you to join in this discussion
that will complement the wonderful words
that you have given us tonight.
Thank you for your hope and
please come back to Yale.
- Yes.
- Visit us.
- Please do come back.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Thanks a lot.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- [Andrew] Thank you.
(chiming music)